after dark in Tokyo a city with some of
the most vibrant and expensive nightlife
in the world following several years of
covid-19 restrictions the Japanese
capital is bouncing back but even if
people are now taking more chances with
their health they're also watching their
wallets we are a Peruvian restaurant so
many people come here because they
cannot go abroad so eating something
that is uh it's a foreign food is kind
of actually uh very popular now but even
if they come more in numbers they are
not consuming the way they used before
Bruno nachandakari's signature dish is
ceviche raw fish marinated in lime juice
a favorite among his customers while
domestic fish prices have remained
relatively stable limes imported from
Mexico have doubled in cost although
he's been holding off that price hike
will soon have to be passed on to diners
Japan like many Western Nations has
followed the lead of the United States
in imposing economic sanctions on Russia
for its war in Ukraine
even projects such as the succulent II
natural gas joint venture which it had
refused to pull out of are now under
threat Russia recently took over the
development and supplies which are
essential to Japan could be cut
Japan's made a real effort to get on to
Renewables but even here they still rely
on fossil fuels for 88 percent of their
primary energy sources like everywhere
else in the world pump prices have
increased between five and ten percent
in the last couple of months with years
of pandemic restrictions expected to
slow Chinese production its neighbors
could also suffer
but here Japan's prospects look rather
better as Asian Supply chains reorganize
they're using Japanese technology to do
so obviously Japan is being heard by The
Incredible cost push inflation Japan is
a big importer of energy is a very big
importer of food and as a result of that
you know the purchasing power of the
people you know is under downward
pressure but Japan is different from the
rest of the world because it's got a
very functioning and very effective
government Japan has been a mourning for
former prime minister Shinzo Abe
assassinated a week ago but his legacy
of a strong stable government and
assertive fiscal policy could be the
best defense the government has in the
face of rising Global inflation Tony
Chang Al Jazeera Tokyo